i actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64.
i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
pattern
you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the five habits you need
to have for an extremely
productive day enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one utilize the power of 64 with david
meltzer
productivity is very simple it's a
measurement to me
i actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64
is that i focus in on having twice as
many productive hours so most people
work eight productive hours i work 16.
i then focus in on the efficiencies of
those hours to turn the 16 hours
to twice as efficient to 32 hours of
production
and then i look at the statistical
success of what i'm doing
to double that to create 64 hours of
production
so when people ask me how do you speak
internationally have your own radio show
on cnbc
run a business have a family of four
kids happy marriage
travel do all these things well it's
easy because i have 64 hours a day
that i'm doing things and it may sound
silly
but i've actually changed my life by
creating and playing with time
let me give you some examples of what to
do i take everything
everything that i do by the minute hour
day
month year and i look at it and i create
systems it may sound a little ocd or
lane or attentive
but it actually works so i took for
example i brushed my teeth lost my teeth
and take listerine every morning
and i took that and i started realizing
that i would days off and forget what
tooth and it took me an average of six
minutes a day
but if i stayed focused in the morning
and that small little thing that i do
every day
i can save four minutes four minutes
time seven day was 28 minutes a week
times four weeks in a month was two
hours a month
times 12 months was 24 hours that i
regained the productivity
all because i stay focused when i brush
my teeth lost my teeth
and take a shot of listerine other
things happen
i realize that time is compressed in the
morning
so i'm not sure if you can looking at me
realize it i've spent
hours of wasted time in the closet
wondering what to wear
i sit there in the morning no matter how
late i am like oh
that or i've lost a sock or i can't find
the right belt
and so i learned this little trick that
i had when i was five years old
is i lay out my clothes at night but the
challenge is when i analyzed that is i
didn't want to take away from the time
with my children at night
so i incorporated that with in laying
out my clothes so i took my girls
and i let them lay out my clothes so
they learned colors
and sizes geography where things were
bought finance
i did all kinds of type of things and
now my six-year-old son
because i travel a lot he actually gets
excited when i leave
because he gets to lay out my clothes
and my oldest daughter who's 17
walks by and tells me oh daddy i miss
laying out your clothes with you
see how this universal energy
has created itself into efficient
effective statistically successful
things in my life
that have nothing to do with business
it's a matter of putting energy and
creating the habits in performance
hey this is dave meltzer and i'm going
to read my favorite paragraph
of my friend evan carmichael's book
built to serve
here's the secret dream big
act small it is important to dream big
your big dreams will motivate you it
will inspire you
to keep going when things get tough
it'll be a rallying call for your
partners
suppliers customers and future employees
keep a hold of your huge dream
and then act small
find the smallest possible way to get
started
to take the first step to get some
momentum going
dream big but act small habit number two
set goals with zig ziglar i want to talk
a little bit about goals
on the light of how do you lose 37
pounds and write a book i'm just going
to
kind of give you that as an example for
24 years of my
adult life by choice i weighed well over
200
pounds i say by choice because you see i
have never
accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate and
when i
choose to eat too much today i have
chosen to weigh too much
tomorrow you can choose to set
goals and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand
that the consequences are not going to
be good
down the road for 24 years i was going
to lose that weight
as a matter of fact in 24 years i lost
several thousand pounds of weight
how many of you already know exactly
what i'm talking about but it wasn't
until i wrote it down put a date on it
listed the obstacles i had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action
set that time limit in there and
identified
all of the benefits to me it was only
when i did that
that the goal became a reality and i
lost
the weight for 10 or 15 years i was
gonna write a book you know anybody
who's gonna do just a whole lot of
things folks
i was gonna write a book but it wasn't
until i got
busy writing the book and writing the
plans first
before the book ever materialized now if
it sounds like i'm trying to sell you on
heaven goals
how many of you are getting close
already how many of you are being coming
convinced
right quick like that you need to have
those goals there's no question about it
the immortal jcpenney many many years
ago said
give me a stock clerk with a goal
and i'll give you a man who will make
history but give me a man
without a goal and i'll give you
a stock clerk now the interesting thing
is goals do not care who
has them let me give you a classic
example of the way they work in 1950
a war-torn devastated japan
a nation which had lost an incredibly
high percentage
of its young men their cities were in
ruins they had been bombed out
but in 1950 they got together they
meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950s
in the production of textiles in 1959
ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in 1960
they set another goal
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world in the production of steel
now when you understand there's no iron
ore in japan of any significance
there's no call of any significance
there we're going to be the number one
nation in the world in the production of
steel
it seemed like an absurd goal and yet
they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970
the japanese set another goal they said
during the 70s we would be the number
one nation in the world in the
production of automobiles
they missed it folks one year it took
them until 1980.
in 1980 they set another goal and this
time their goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world in the production of
computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely
must have those goals you got to write
them down you got to put a date on it
you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you've got to find out what it is you
need to know you got to develop a plan
of action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me now that's a formula
that i have just given you pure and
simple habit number three
only do five things per day with gabby
bernstein
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time
or we're not productive at all because
we don't know where to start i found
personally being in business for myself
for the last
20 years that i have been a little
overly productive i almost did too much
and i was
constantly multitasking and making
things happen and just moving
so fast that ultimately i really burnt
out
and i started feeling brain fog i was
feeling disoriented i couldn't focus i
was feeling like
even though i for so many years was
priding myself on the fact that i could
get so much done at one time
i actually don't think i was being
nearly as productive as i could have
been
so i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways
i was then blessed um i said a prayer i
said i need some help with my brain fog
and i need some help with my
productivity issue
and i that day got an email from the dr
oz show asking me to come on and do a
segment with
this lovely author and dr dr mike dao
and me and mike had been in touch many
years
for many years just because he hadn't
been an author we were published by the
same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day
i'm like thank you universe you're
giving me exactly what i need
i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling
so chaotic and i'm multitasking so much
and my
i feel like i've got brain fog and i'm
forgetting things and he looked at me
says
how much are you doing at one time and i
said oh mike i'm doing a million things
at once i have a thousand tabs up on my
screen
and he's like these are big brain
no-no's and they're also productivity
no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multi-task
the less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion
was to just do five things a day to make
a list of the five most important things
that i need to do that day
and not do number two until i've
completed number one
and then once i complete number one move
on to number two then on to number three
and if i don't get through all five in
one day i'll just pick up the fifth
the next day or wherever i left off i'll
pick up the next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things
added on to that list and just be really
committed to that five
task list i did it i started to just be
very clear about the five things i was
doing in a day i told my team
i made a a list in my base camp which is
where we keep all of our notes
and i made it really clear to myself
these are the only five things i'm doing
throughout the day as a result of making
it
super clear and conscious to myself that
i was only going to do five things i
have been more productive
i have created more have been more
intuitive
i have been more inspired and i've been
more creative
habit number four manage your activities
with bob proctor
think of this for a moment do you know
that every living soul
gets exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time figure
it out
you get all there is a hobo
sleeping under a bridge or on a park
bench
that has no material possessions none
does nothing of any constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time
as the most productive industrialist
in the world we all get exactly the same
amount of time
so it's what we do with the time that
makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun
has time management programs in fact i
made one one time spent a lot of money
on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago and i was
going with him on a speaking engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever earl nigel said you want to
meet me i was there and i always had
some well-prepared questions
and i remember asking him i said how did
you learn how to master
time management you know we're having
breakfast i can still hear his fork hit
the plate
he's what the hell are you talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
he's i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket and he said every night before i
go to bed
i write down six most important things i
have to do tomorrow these are goal
achieving activities
and when i wake up that's what i start
working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six now if i have
three that i didn't get done today that
doesn't mean i have
nine for tomorrow like six plus these
three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up you give all your
conscious attention to do those things
see you cannot manage time but you can
manage activity
you can manage your activities make
certain that what you're doing really
makes a difference
makes certain that you're spending your
time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
and habit number five the last one
before very special bonus clip is
structure your goals as
questions with brian tracy there's a
process which has made more people
rich than any other single process of
goals
achieving and it's to take your major
goal and structure it as a question
if your goal is to earn one hundred
thousand dollars a year
then you write how can i earn one
hundred thousand dollars
in the next 12 months that's an
open-ended question
not how can i earn it at my job or doing
a specific thing just an open-ended
question how can i earn the amount of
money
and then you discipline yourself to
write 20 answers to the question
and the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of
to earn a hundred thousand dollars work
longer
work harder uh upgrade my skills
get a new job would take a part-time
opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question the 20
question method called mindstorming
forces you to dig
deep deep into your mind where you will
find
all your answers and it may be call a
person uh
read a book uh let me give you an
example uh we had a young fellow
entrepreneur he got 35 years old he
built a successful business
he worked about 10 years to do it and he
for two years wanted to sell his
business so he could take a year off and
travel
enjoy his money and so for two years he
just sort of
floundered around like a fish on the
dock wanting to sell his business
nobody offered to buy it he suggested it
to people
people were not interested and so on and
in this exercise that they put him
through
his 20th answer and often it's the 20th
answer that is the breakthrough
was buy a book on how to sell
your own business and it just went off
like a flash bulb in his mind
at the break he got up as a downtown
hotel got up
went down the street to a major
bookstore went and found
he was amazed at the number of books had
been written on how to buy and sell a
business
so he bought two or three books two
months later he had restructured
packaged his business sold it completely
satisfactorily and took a year off
he said but just a single idea it was a
breakthrough idea
but it was so simple just get a book on
the subject and you think
boy that's pretty obvious yes but it's
the most obvious answers that we
overlook
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you if you're losing energy during the
day and you want to nap
every afternoon you're not being
productive like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win
i think everybody should get a sleep
test i think it's a brutal experience
you don't you barely sleep right when
you're there you got stuff up your nose
and a million centers all over you but
to know how much sleep you actually need
uh and making sure that you're
productive during the time that you are
awake that's the most important thing
that you are productive during the time
that you're awake is way more important
than if you wake up before the sun gets
up
okay so how can you do it i'm going to
give you a three-step process that i
think will help
step number one is fix your calendar fix
your calendar you got to make sure that
you're productive make sure your actions
map to your emissions the reason why
so many people say wake up early is
because your evening hours for many
people are not productive
because when you wake up you're more
likely to be productive and you're gonna
you're gonna do your work you're gonna
get on your morning routine you're gonna
feel like you've got a kick start on the
day you're gonna go off and start to
crush it
where if you're staying up late at night
you're gonna find yourself playing games
or watching netflix you're doing things
that aren't productive right
like waking hours make sure you're
productive
put it in your calendar you're waking up
around this time right
how are you gonna spend your morning
routine what does that look like and
then what are you going to do
and mapping it out so that when you can
step above your calendar and look at the
week and the month that's ahead you say
if i did these things that's in my
calendar
i'm going to be more successful i'm
going to be closing in on my goals right
your actions map to your ambitions
so you create your calendar and then you
go and live it
and then you go and do it the most
important thing again isn't
making sure you're up before the sun
it's making sure that you're doing the
things that you said you were going to
do
and the things that you said you were
going to do are going to lead you to
accomplishing the success that you want
to have
you have to be more productive and fix
your calendar step number two is
understand how much sleep you actually
need
right i i've heard it i guess before but
i didn't really buy it until i went and
did the sleep study
and again i'm still trying to hack it i
still believe i can get it lower
even if i go from nine to eight that's
amazing
but i have to be fully refreshed i have
to be ready to start my day and so
understand how much sleep you need right
here's a challenge
for tomorrow don't set an alarm and see
what time you wake up and if
and you sleep an extra hour and you feel
more refreshed
like you're probably living in a massive
sleep deficit
for you and so maybe you need seven
hours or maybe you need eight hours or
maybe you need nine hours
and if you need a lot more than that
then maybe you know there's a problem
you got to go get it fixed
i was hoping that he could give me uh
like if i had sleep apnea amazing
my problem with sleep apnea awesome give
me the machine i'll sleep with every
night i'll sleep seven hours and i'll go
and crush it's like no you don't have
sleep apnea
you don't you don't have any
deficiencies i did a bunch of blood
tests no deficiencies there's nothing
actually wrong with you you just need
nine hours sleep it just tears me apart
but you have to figure out how much
sleep you need because again sacrificing
one hour of sleep
and being tired all day is not going to
make you more productive
understand how much sleep you need and
then factor that into your calendar
factor that into your life so you can be
happy you can be fulfilled you can have
energy you can go and crush your goals
and then step number three is work to
your rhythm some people work better at
night than they do during the day
right again as i said earlier the reason
why so many people advocate for
a morning start is because at night
most people aren't productive at night
you're losing time at night you're
watching netflix and playing games and
doing things that aren't in supportive
of your mission right listen to grant
though he goes to sleep at nine
greco don't go to sleep at night and he
wakes up before the sun comes up he's
getting enough sleep to do it
right but your best productivity might
be at nine like maybe you don't even
turn on until nine maybe you should be
working
from nine until four in the morning
right
work to your style because if you try to
be somebody else and you try to work to
a different style that's not
suited for you you're not gonna win it's
more difficult if you're working from
nine
you know p.m to four a.m how many hours
is that
10 11 12 that's seven hours right if
you're working from
nine to five the other way
uh that's gonna be hard to do meetings
it's gonna be hard to have team calls
it's gonna be hard to
uh scale up your business right it'll be
difficult because most people don't
wanna work
for a midnight meeting with you but if
that's where you are your most creative
and that's where you
get the most productivity out of you
then you need to factor that in
if you're more of a night owl and you're
gonna work every night you're gonna move
forward on your ambitions
every night then don't beat yourself up
because you didn't get up before the sun
came
if you want to know the five goal
setting habits that you need to develop
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i want to have
that that long-term goal
so embedded in my mind